DANA PERINO!
"THE FIVE."
IT IS OFFICIAL, THE 23 HAD A
JACK-IN-THE-BOX JUST GREW
ANOTHER HEAD.
AND BOY, IS IT EMPTY.
>> THERE IS PLENTY OF MONEY IN
THIS WORLD.
THERE IS PLENTY OF MONEY IN THE
COUNTRY, IT IS JUST IN THE WRONG
HANDS.
>> THE QUINNIPIAC POLL THAT
SHOWED 26% OF NEW YORK VOTERS,
72% OF NEW YORK DEMOCRAT SAY
THAT YOU SHOULD NOT RUN.
>> THE POLE THAT MATTERS IS THE
ELECTION, NEW YORKERS HAVE SAID
THAT TWICE THAT THEY WANT ME TO
LEAD THEM, I CALL THEM CON DON,
WE KNOW HIS TRICKS AND HIS
PLAYBOOK.
I KNOW HOW TO TAKE HIM ON, I'VE
BEEN WATCHING IT FOR DECADES.
>> Greg: ONE OF THE MOST INAPT
TO IN HUMAN HISTORY HAS DECIDED
TO TAKE HIS INCOMPETENCE
NATIONAL VOWING TO STEAL YOUR
MONEY AND SPREAD IT AROUND.
BUT I GUESS IF EVERYONE IN YOUR
CITY HATES YOU, RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT IS BETTER THAN GETTING
RUN OUT OF TOWN.
NO ONE LIKES THIS GUY.
HERE'S SOME PROOF.
>> WORSE MAYOR EVER!
WORSE MAYOR EVER!
>> LIAR!
LIAR!
>> YOU CAN'T RUN THE CITY, YOU
CAN'T RUN THE COUNTRY!
YOU CAN'T RUN THE CITY COMING
YOU CAN'T RUN THE COUNTRY!
>> Greg: POLICE, BUSINESS
OWNERS, TAXIS, THEY ALL HATE
HIM.
HE IS MORE DESPISED THAN
ANTHONY WEINER.
HE IS ANTHONY WEINER WITHOUT THE
WEINER JOKES, IN OTHER WORDS, HE
IS NOTHING.
61% JUMP OF HOMELESS FROM 2002.
BUT HE CANNOT SEE THAT, HE KEEPS
HIS TINTED WINDOWS ROLLED UP.
MEANWHILE WHERE IT IS A CHUNK OF
YOUR PAYCHECK GO?
TO HIS WIFE THAT SPENT HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS ON A PROGRAM FOR THE
MENTALLY ILL WITH NO VISIBLE
RESULTS, EXCEPT THAT THERE IS
MORE MENTALLY ILL.
WAS THAT THE POINT?
HE HAS POWER AT ITS WORST.
COERCION MIXED WITH CRONYISM.
AND TAKEN OUT BY THE ADULTS THAT
HE SCOFFS, MEANING THE POLICE
WHO MAKE THE CITY SAVER SO THAT
BILL CAN RUIN OTHER THINGS.
HE BENEFITS FROM THEM, BUT ALSO
THE PAST.
RUDY GIULIANI AND BLOOMBERG
REBUILT THE CITY THAT IS STRONG
ENOUGH TO ENDURE THE LUMBERING
YOUR CHURCH.
HE IS GAMBLING WITH SOMEBODY
ELSE'S CHIPS.
AND HE GOT REELECTED, WHY?
NOBODY VOTED.
WHEN ONE PARTY RUNS THE JOINT,
WHY BOTHER?
AMERICA IS DIFFERENT, THE MOMENT
THAT THEY GET THEIR TASTE OF
de BLASIO, IT WILL BE A
NATIONWIDE HURL.
PREPARE TO DUCK.
ALL RIGHT, DAGEN McDOWELL, WHY
IS HE DOING THIS?
THIS IS NUTS.
EVEN HIS OWN PARTY --
LET ME SHARE THE POLL.
EVEN HIS OWN PARTY CAN'T STAND
HIM.
DO YOU HAVE THE POLL THAT
SHOWS --
WOULD YOU LIKE TO SEE BILL
DE BLASIO RUN FOR PRESIDENT IN
2020?
76% NO.
THE DEMOCRATS I THINK IT IS
ABOUT 74%, WHY?
>> Dagen: NEVER UNDERESTIMATE
THE ARROGANCE AND SELF-DELUSION
OF A POLITICIAN.
WHY IS HE RUNNING?
IN NEW YORK CITY HE IS REVILED.
HE IS BOO-80, WHAT DO YOU THINK
OF MAYOR de BLASIO, THEY GIVE
YOU THIS LOOK.
IT IS LIKE THEY JUST WALKED BY A
DUMPSTER BEHIND A SEAFOOD
RESTAURANT.
WHAT HE NEEDS TO GO OUT AND GO
INTO THE SOUTH AND MIDWEST AND
TRY TO FEED HIS EGO.
AGAIN, WHAT WAS JEB BUSH'S LINE?
PLEASE CLAP.
THAT'S WHAT WE'LL DO.
HE NEEDS DEFEATED SOME HOW.
>> Greg: DANA, THIS IS THE
COVER OF THE POST, AND USUALLY
THEY WILL RIP YOU, BUT THEY
CAN'T EVEN, BECAUSE I CAN'T TAKE
IT SERIOUSLY.
THEY ARE LIKE ABSOLUTELY -- WHAT
CAN YOU SAY, DANA?
>> Dana: ONE OF MY FAVORITE
THINGS ABOUT MOVING TO NEW YORK
AS "THE NEW YORK POST" COVERS
EVERY DAY.
THEY DID NOT DISAPPOINT.
YOU KNOW WHEN HE SAID WE HAVE
PLENTY OF MONEY IN THIS HAND, I
THOUGHT THE SAME THING.
THEY ANNOUNCED A COUPLE OF
MONTHS AGO THAT THEY WASTED
$1 BILLION ON THE MENTAL HEALTH
EFFORTS, BUT ALSO IN THE SAME
WEEK THEY HAD TO ANNOUNCE THAT
THEY SPENT ABOUT $1 BILLION ON
AN EDUCATION EFFORT AND GOT NO
RESULTS FROM THAT EITHER.
I'M NOT SURE THAT THE MONEY IS
EXACTLY IN THE WRONG HANDS, BUT
RUNNING RIGHT NOW IS SEEN AS ITS
OWN REWARD.
SO HE PROBABLY DOES NOT ONCE, HE
IS BIGGER THAN NEW YORK CITY,
RIGHT?
I HAVE TO TAKE THIS GENIUS ON
THE ROAD AND WHAT HELPS?
INSTANT NAME I.D., GOING TO
START TALKING BADLY ABOUT YOU,
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT YOU.
HE WILL BE ASKED HIS OPINION OF
THINGS, HE WILL ALSO IN HIS
OBITUARY ALWAYS SAY NO, AS A GUY
WHO RAN FOR PRESIDENT IN 2020,
HE WILL ALWAYS AT LEAST HALF
THAT.
IT IS A STEPPING STONE TO OTHER
THINGS.
I JUST DON'T KNOW WHERE --
>> Greg: A PLACE AT THE
ADMINISTRATION, I DON'T KNOW,
JESSE -- HE BLATANTLY SAID HE IS
GOING TO TAKE YOUR MONEY.
AT LEAST HE IS HONEST ABOUT
BEING A COMMUNIST.
>> Jesse: THAT'S WHY HE IS
RUNNING NATIONALLY IS BECAUSE HE
WILL SELL ACCESS TO CITY HALL IN
MANHATTAN, THIS IS NOT A
NATIONAL GIG FOR HIM.
HE IS THE ONLY LIBERAL
POLITICIAN, GREG, THAT THE
LIBERAL MEDIA DOES NOT LIKE.
YOU HAVE TO BE PRETTY UNLIKABLE
FOR THE LIBERAL MEDIA NOT TO
LIKE YOU.
HE IS AN OBNOXIOUS GUY --
>> Greg: COMING FROM YOU!
>> Dana: [LAUGHS]
>> Jesse: WALL STREET HATES
HIM, NYPD HATES HIM, EVEN THE
RICH PEOPLE ON THE UPPER WEST
SIDE OF HIM HATE HIM.
HE DOES NOT PLOW THE SNOW WHEN
IT COMES OUT, SO THIS GUY,
REALLY THE ONLY REASON THAT HE
IS DOING THIS IS TO HAVE AN OFF
RAMP FOR HIS CAREER AFTER HIS
TERM IS OVER, ALL OF HIS
INITIATIVES ARE SUNK.
LIKE MEATLESS MONDAY IS, ARE YOU
KIDDING ME?
HE SHOWS UP LATE TO WORK, HE
HIDES IN THE OUTER BOROUGHS
COMING YOU NEVER REALLY SEE HIM
IN THE RIBBON CUTTING CEREMONY,
THROWING OUT THE FIRST PITCH OF
THE BASEBALL GAME.
HE DOES NOT RIDE THE SUBWAY,
BECAUSE HE KNOWS THAT THE
AVERAGE JOE HATES HIM AND IS
GOING TO HECKLE HIM.
THE SAME THING, WHEN HE KILLED
THE GROUNDHOG ON GROUNDHOG DAY,
THAT WAS IT.
THERE WAS NO COMING BACK FROM
THAT.
>> Greg: YOU ARE AN ANIMAL
LOVER.
>> Jesse: I AM NOW.
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT, THE ONE
THING THAT HE IS DOING, JUAN, HE
IS GOING TO PULL THIS LARGE
GROUP EVEN FURTHER TO THE LEFT
AND MAKE BITE IN THE EVEN MORE
REASONABLE LOOKING?
IS THAT PART OF THE STRATEGY?
HE IS NOT THAT SMART.
>> I DO NOT THINK THAT IS THE
STRATEGY, BUT I THINK THAT TRUMP
IS LESS POPULAR THAN de BLASIO
IN NEW YORK CITY.
AND HE HAS WON TWICE.
>> Greg: THAT IS TRUE,
PROBABLY.
>> Juan: THAT IS TRUE
OBVIOUSLY, BUT THE ONE THING
ABOUT de BLASIO IS THAT HE PUT
OUT A VIDEO TODAY, WORKING
PEOPLE FIRST, AND IT IS ALL
ABOUT INCOME INEQUALITY.
THAT'S WHY YOU SAYS THERE IS A
LOT OF MONEY IN AMERICA, BUT IT
IS IN THE WRONG HANDS.
HE HAS A POINT.
>> Greg: WHO DECIDES WHO IS
THE WRONG HANDS?
WHO IS THE WRONG HAND?
>> Juan: WHEN THE MIDDLE CLASS
FEELS LIKE WE ARE NOT GETTING
HURT, THE SYSTEM IS FIXED,
PEOPLE ARE FRUSTRATED.
SO HE HAS A POINT, BUT THE
PROBLEM IS THAT ELIZABETH WARREN
IS ALREADY IN THAT LANE, ISN'T
SHE, ELIZABETH WARREN ALSO HAS
SOLUTIONS AND IDEAS AND
PROPOSAL, I DON'T SEE THAT
COMING FROM BILL de BLASIO.
I WILL SAY THIS WHEN IT COMES TO
REAL ACCOMPLISHMENT, HE CAN
POINT TO UNIVERSAL PREPAID, HE
WAS TALKING ABOUT THAT TODAY.
THE CRIME RATE IS DOWN.
THE COPS MAY NOT LIKE HIM, BUT
GUESS WHAT, THE CRIME RATE IS
DOWN.
A >> Greg: THIS IS THE TRUE
IRONY FOR LEFT-WING CLEAN COAL
LIKE de BLASIO, THE MURDER
RATE IS WAY DOWN, THAT IS DUE TO
THE COPS SAVING THE CITY.
SO THE IRONY IS THAT THE PEOPLE
THAT de BLASIO DOES NOT LIKE
HER SAVING HIS ASS.
A >> Juan: THAT IS NOT TRUE
THAT HE DOES NOT LIKE THEM.
HE HAS OVERSEEN WHAT IS GOING ON
WITH THE POLICE AND IN THE CITY.
>> Greg: THEY WANT TO KEEP FAR
AWAY.
>> Juan: WHAT KIND OF
CONTROVERSY?
HOW UNPOPULAR?
>> Greg: THAT WAS THE GOLDEN
YEARS COMPARED.
A >> Juan: MAY BE FOR YOU, BUT
NOT FOR MOST PEOPLE.
I WILL SAY THAT BLOOMBERG IS
OTHER MAYOR THAT RAN.
AND THIS IS THE BIGGEST CITY IN
THE COUNTRY, PEOPLE DO KNOW WHO
THE MAYOR OF NEW YORK IS COMING
INTO THE IDEA IS IF YOU CAN RUN
THIS SHIP, MAYBE YOU CAN RUN THE
BIG SHIP.
>> Dagen: I WILL BE BRIEF,
THIS IS DANGEROUS BECAUSE HIS
RECORD IN NEW YORK CITY AS A
CHECKLIST FOR WHY BIG
GOVERNMENTS FAIL THOSE IN NEED.
YOU KNOW, PEOPLE WHO WERE IN THE
MIDDLE COMING EVENT WILL BUY
THAT SOMETIMES THAT WE NEED MORE
MONEY ON EDUCATION TO SAVE
CHILDREN WHO ARE AT RISK ON
HOMELESSNESS TO HELP THE
MENTALLY ILL ON PUBLIC HOUSING,
AND EVERY SINGLE BOX IS A
FAILURE FOR THIS MAYOR.
SO IT SHINES A LIGHT ON HOW
BUREAUCRATS DO NOT TAKE CARE OF
THOSE WHO ARE THE MOST IN NEED.
DESPITE VAST AMOUNTS OF MONEY.